hi guys and
I
nice to be here myself and my colleagues
has been coming for the past three years
so it's nice to be back so let's see all
right so this again hello CSS huh and
everything is done in CSS 3d well a bit
of like a floating debris is if I don't
know if you like gravity or best era
alright alright so my top today the up
line will be talking about Tubba pjs why
this talk is about CSS 3d renderer and a
bit of history like you know what we're
behind the scenes as a developer and you
know a bit of what goes under the hood
in this renderer no Bo you know what
what's gonna happen next are we going to
use this stuff a day so three dot CSS 3
dot CSS 3d render that's the convention
that we use for the 3gs library but
first you will say what you know why are
we talking about a GS like real Tecna
CSS conference and in fact it's probably
not you know maybe talk about three
years many people you know this uh Bobby
says that the JavaScript library for
back via I mean you could look at es
it's only a josh a backyard library or
you could think that art is the best
javascript library for free jet you know
hopefully it later and and and so so one
thing for that is that great things
doesn't belong alone it's
cut juice which is the nickname my
colleagues give me and maybe we'll go
mon Dieu why you know what good things
doesn't have to be you know what doesn't
have to be alone or why I things alone
so BR 3gs is a JavaScript library and
it's hosted on github what number of
contributors and you can see quite a bit
of following and in a guy behind that
Ricardo otherwise known as mr. bill it's
started this project so a bit of 3gs
like it's a rendering engine and you use
that to render scene so there's only
four things that you need first it is a
sin second is objects objects can be
measures you know 3d models materials
light a grouping of 3d objects and Telus
camera where since this is a budget
releasing you want to do have a camera
to capture like what the camera sees and
you have perspective and photographic
perspective is what is what your eye
sees like as things goes out how this
goes down the road you know the houses
appear smaller orthography is like when
you use it like for some autographic
drawings like the same objects of the
same size appear to be the same length
when it's maybe on paper or on your
screen and lastly spread the road and so
is sorry you can see that this really
you know not just better in the room yes
chemist renderer bacteria SVG software
renderer I will not go so much into it
but the idea is that 3gs is a web
you know JavaScript rendering engine
where you could basically say that you
know you have a senior objects you could
use a perspective camera camera
orthographic camera and likewise the
renderer kinda modular you know you
could play a chemist renderer for web we
are in durham and how much renderer has
been more popular or the past years
because back we are is not be supported
like on many platforms but like with iOS
8 we have mobile devices running back
here so in a new releases of 3gs like
bacteria is the default 3gs renderer so
it's how you do it in code where you
have a scene you know you're right noon
same camera a new perspective camera and
render oh yeah new babe gia render and
you add objects fiber objects to the
scene and the car ended up render the
scene and camera passing so nice thing
about the CSS video and array is that it
works like almost aware you will see for
a WebGL see a second set of a new tree
German Darrell you would actually use
CSS 3d render and you do the same which
is you include a 3gs library you include
the CSS 3d render JavaScript farm
because it does not come with the
default view is this is in a sauce in
the github repository and you create Dom
elements a basic back then in 3d objects
and
3ds 3ds practice and then they see and
then you could have any made Emma
interactivity so as I mentioned if you
wrap them in 3d objects are 3d sprites
so basically you can just create a Dom
element and and basically the difference
is that a 3d object kind of has a
perspective like when you rotate it if
you say it's like a paper being rotated
in 3d space while at release flag is
like a beer bar which faces you all the
time that is the one in the middle
alright so I mean why will you use a CSS
3d render night you know yeah WebGL is
gaining popularity you know it runs on
iOS and no longer problem IE 11 runs
bactria so why CSS 3d so what a benefit
which I wish I think it is really great
about this is that it's really
lightweight in fact if you if you take
all the things that just this to render
to leave your package the library for
with the CSS 3d render without bacteria
or canvas is probably before GZ is a
rocky Cavey so it's very small you know
not not a concern right the default I
think the back job you is about 200 200
kb so matter benefits like if you are
used if you are web developer and you
you are used to having Dom elements so
this is really great like instead of
missing a vector in a standard flow you
have to create a 3d models like some
form of a geometry and then you have to
create materials say a basic material
you know if a flat shading or you could
have a look lumber shading so so you
have to put lights in there and
calculate what how smooth shading or is
it flexion in that unit but policy for
CSS 3d render is this just an amazing
elements so no Shay does no material no
measures which really simple and so that
the things they are animating is yes CSS
sub which is because the star in
whatever ways in life I'd like to put a
curve radius model to it you could do it
and when you have all these objects
which are any way through you could
actually a Dom events Angela right we're
going to mouse over mouse click well in
a typical web jockey mesh renderer the
browser vendors to a canvas which is
basically and what you get is you do a
mouse move you get have get academics
and you have to do a kick to find back
what object you actually the cursor is
on this mobile friendly it runs on quite
many mobile devices and draw iOS and
it's pretty performer so then this year
John Brown he actually gave a talk scss
comfy you on his experience working
using the CSS 3d render with for
projects for google like for example the
showcase a website of google.com / our
own so it is a recommended top and if
you have done you know grammar check
data and slice of history probably too
small to read but there I'll just go
ahead does that explain so I mean if you
watch iron man you will see that is
navigating some
using the faces
right and oops
love it
and
and the story goes that famous actually
wrote the library to have to be able to
do like obvious render on your iPad and
so they so there is the famous library
for deck and Ricardo stud good kind of
black sea okay you know my snake is not
to say it's not back yeah it's not
converse so what lies that he has to be
CSS 3d and and so mr. Duke did this
experiment himself there you have it
and rotate it
so I this is in CSS 3d
all right yeah i mean this this is a
screen shot of you know of this i'm
running an ipad suddenly say okay great
but how does it work and the thing
behind this is 3d transforms yes
actually transforms and let's let me
just do a quick demo and so this another
example which comes in a previous
examples in and you can see this is
basically rendering a panoramic view in
a in a sky box and if we take if we
inspect the element you can see these
are all bound elements it's basically
image and if you so less this
Cilic
and you can see that the matrices are
changing so this is how CSS 3d render it
works maybe a big too complex and and so
I will do try a bit of light coating so
this is basically that's a relief in a
really simple HTML file let's just hit
the body and the d200 fix str Crixus so
let's use them
fun and let's try skill
x
and see that it changes may be less the
area fine with the step transition yeah
not recommended to use off a performer
results back you know for laziness I
will just do that is in and if I play
around this number can see that it moves
okay so now we let's try rotate and we
try wrap it say z 5 degrees maybe a bit
more for some defect and okay rotate Z
words and now let's try rotate y orata
types
and it's kind of strange like nothing's
happening so so why why is this
happening so what you have to do is that
you have to go to parent element and add
a perspective number and there you have
it it gets
and you see that the mattresses that
you've seen before in in in the previous
example so you could you could do like
metrics and then you four five six
arguments this is shocking for that more
arguments for metrics 3d
so this can control the skill and this
controls like the translation yeah
matrix is kind of scary like you know I
I did not like of these mathematics and
do when I start playing this and it's
actually not too difficult yeah this is
the documentation mvn like matrix what
parameters to use and if you like to
learn more about matrices Steven videos
as has a good time making back job dance
where you have like explains how
mattresses work it's basically a matrix
content rotation skill and translation
in the concise way and this is what the
CSS 3d render is doing it applies it to
the to the Dom element so that you don't
have to do likes qxu across the x and
that becomes really lengthy so what are
the limitations why you know in what
ways the CSS Philly when the right isn't
that good so first browser but this was
this was brought up in John Brown's talk
to when I does not support physically so
physically this basically if you have a
3d object in a 2d object and you
basically users have to it maintains
like a coordinates in a child object and
and without that you can just add
objects and objects and we retain the
perspective so there are solutions where
is 3d render I and an intersection
problems like chrome may not be able to
render it went to dislike intersect and
may not have shows the
the dead properly so next restoration so
what happens behind the scene is that
when you use this seed transforms is
dead it gets sense to the GPU so GPU is
to simply say that it's a piece of
hardware which does graphics and
actually does it it's much more
efficient to do it on the hardware and
do it in software and and so this is
about I did have immediate metrics and
oh and what I wonder demonstrate is that
if you zoom in
you can see that it is capitulated so
this is restoration like if you it's not
like in in if you have a plane in
bacteria and zoomy you can to see that
that's a straight line but over here
when you don't mean that you can see
that it gets accelerated it's not not
really a big problem okay let's just lay
around this let's go on you can ask you
it so when you wrap text if you create a
text element you could have sizing up to
maybe hire fixes and then you get chris
years and the next thing is lei Li me so
I was basic X experimenting and and and
and we had so mr. dilip at this
experiment which wich years ago used to
run performance and when I tried out
like that this is in 2012 and it was a
trending one frame per second and so
what possibly change over the years is
the way the browser renders the web page
and
so this was the experiment which I was
playing with which was kind of like
clone of his experiment and enter the
dead of view is basically i'm applying a
CSS blur filter three have limited that
objects are leather lab lab okay in in
photography so I thought this was is
origin expert experiment and and most
interesting that this was done it's not
with CSS render it was delivered on
renderer so when I went ham Louis
experimenting but we know wise this is
no it's not serious it's not canvas is
not baptized CSS 3d render so I was
starting to dig up the history of like
how creatures evolved which was
basically used to bring the Dom elements
and so some other tests I did which was
like and slowly a like kappa i read
elements and when i hit a thousand we
see the frames per second should drop to
about 10 frames a second so what happens
is that there's a limit to how many
layers that you could that you could
actually enemy if the cssp director but
my place is there every time you use a
trance electronique you know the
translate the heck you are creating a
layer and that layer becomes is supposed
to be accelerator and and i say the
browser composite that we have to put
them together so sao paulo is who is a
developer ok for huger has this article
saying bye bye Lea hex like hell of your
chains so I don't like you know we have
found it translate Z is pretty good like
you know you mix things and it made much
faster if you abuse this feature you
know and you hit like a thousand objects
of this your web page is going to slow
down like really badly and he has a
really that occur visa you're making
layers is considered dangerous so but as
long as you know like what Adam is our I
think it's good to know like how the
browser is rendering and and so you
would not you know does not apply
translate Z on everything and now it
means this closet browser to hang so
what question is can CSS 3d render on
regular matches like you know like with
the other renderers triggers so this was
an ax prime I wish I did basically
turning a huger object your ambassador
that the CSS 3d render doesn't use
geometry
but if it take the user geometry items
in this case is here I could have
translated back into the be rendered
with CSS 3d so my place is the heavy
line here is messages a dominant and now
it is interesting article suspect as a
stack overflow and some vast language is
one big contributors his reactive 3gs
community lab you know helping before
and this capsule max bhangra you know
but his it's pretty interesting like you
know how different people me without a
graphics background we you know we come
together and there's so many interesting
things that come from this 3gs ecosystem
so you got twitter app i think this was
this year are pushing the limits so this
was its approach to render for branding
measures
the vicious
30 New York you can always fight this
back with google yeah so this is the
classic flocking the butt system
in three years but so in CSS reading
that leaves around a place
and
performance so not only random Mexico
actually emulate the kind of lacking you
have in WebGL
and
and what what the more complex is on
purse like giving your friend doing is
the support animation we see them that
is how is this possible all right so so
this is another example CSS 3d render me
use
and so this link is locked we're
actually find it you could you have a
editor you can actually create stuff
but apart from these like kind of random
measures we BBC text is hitting the
limits like it runs like animate the
house reference per second so the
question is is this I know you know the
CSS 3d render so my partner is
impractical like you know it's used in
the google i/o showcase this other
experiments which like the following
link shows how you could use WebGL
together CSS 3d render because bacteria
as a support rendering text of the box
so you put actually basically just use
text in your Dom elements and and
because it makes perfectly I come back
we are the CSS you can actually like
have a great neighbors with that more
demos don't I think we might not have
time for this let the experiment for
Christmas and I share add some by
imaging so okay so I think I'll
summer-like 3gs isn't just know it's
really popular for back pure it isn't
just like there and sometimes we don't
have to think like no should we use this
or use that is it better sometimes it
could be compliments and ideas
unrestricted platforms like ideas in a
VFX industry you know is what I would
like to see in Vietnam graphics on the
browser's you know ideas which famous
has could be used in three years and and
the simplicity of this renderer he has a
special place in here though you know
these days I and I see I love doing back
now and so I
the animal top thank you that's my treat
ahead wow I always love the demos please
huge applause for that could you please
elaborate on how the shading of the
polygons worth like for example the
horse okay so for that it's that uses a
slightly cheaper version of the CSS 3d
render that kind of like it does needs
to cut calculate like its shading so
basically picked up the face normals and
there is your classic computer graphics
and of algorithms like you take the
normal and the direction of the light
and you kind of let me do a dot vector I
mean sorry a dot a dot product and you
can find it you know how much like you
know how how bright you perceive get to
be so that is done in JavaScript and
then you have like this modify the color
of the domina moon if you actually ever
used 3d CSS in a normal website to use
that that's open some way no yeah yeah i
mean i have if you go to the j s comp
website uses a lot of 3d translations I
try to make use of it somehow I'm sure
there will be more uses in the future
how to use 3d CSS to actually give more
personality to websites in normal web
sites like every day shopping website
could use 3d CSS because all that stuff
doesn't just works in your browser right
so thanks again applause for joshua i
think
you